بالصواريخ والمسيرات هجمات متبادله بين
الولايات المتحده وميليشيات ايران في
سوريا صعدت من التوتر ودفعت بالرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن للتحذير بان بلاده
ستتصرف بقوه لحمايه الامريكيين
لا تسيء الفهم الولايات المتحده لا تسعى
الى الصراع مع ايران ولكن توقعوا ان نتصرف
بقوه من اجل حمايه شعبنا هذا بالضبط ما
حدث ليله الماضيه
المتحدث باسم الامن القومي بالبيت الابيض
اوضح ان الضربات الامريكيه في سوريا تهدف
الى حمايه الجنود الامريكيين وانه لا
ينبغي لطهران ان تشارك في دعم الهجمات على
المنشات الامريكيه بينما اكد مسؤول في
البنتاغون ان قوات بلاده في المنطقه في
حاله تاهب التحذير الامريكي قابله رد من
قوات مواليه لايران في سوريا بيان نشر على
الانترنت ذكرت فيه ان لديها اليد الطول
للرد على اي ضربات امريكيه اخرى على
مواقعها وفي تفاصيل الضربه شنت واشنطن
ضربات جويه دقيقه ضد منشات تستخدمها
مجموعات تابعه للحرس الثوري الايراني شرق
سوريا ليلى الجمعه ردا على هجوم بطائره
مسيره تقول واشنطن انها ايرانيه استهدف
منشاه صيانه في قاعده لقوات التحالف قرب
الحسكه ما ادى الى مقتل متعاقد امريكي
وجرح اخرين
ملوك الشيخ العربي